For a house of size 1800 square feet we pay about $126,000.
This is this the dot over here.
I think you get the story.
In a scatter plot, each data item becomes a point.
We conveniently chose a 2-dimensional list to make for a 2-dimensional scatter plot.
These are the most popular scatter plots because surfaces like paper are 2-dimensional.
It's really hard to do it in like 125 dimensions.
Being as it is, when I draw in all the six data points, I get a scatter plot like this.
That's a nice scatter plot, because I can draw a line straight through all of the data points.
Now when this happens and there's a relationship that's governed by a straight line,
we call the data linear.
Now, linearity is a rare concept in statistics.
Very often you'll find deviations, and that's because the size of the house is not
the only determinant in the cost or perhaps because most of us are bad negotiators.
But when a data set is linear, it's really easy to predict prices of houses in between.
For example, a house of this size ought to cost this much.
You can read out of a scatter plot the dependence of the size of a house and its price.
Here we are--we're actually looking at the data.
We're doing what a statistician ought to do.